on the mound making his fifth start of
the season he's had two up and two down
the last two have been tough for him
including a bad matchup against the
yankees just four runs recorded or four
runs allowed seven outs recorded byron
buxton's gonna lead the way for
minnesota tied for the most home runs in
the american league with seven and he's
gonna go the other way
josh naylor fading back and it's gone
second pitch of the game byron buxton
muscles up it's his eighth home run of
the season and the twins grab a one
nothing lead
it's easy power jim total boy this guys
this guy is on a roll i mean
you know that ball actually got a little
bit deep on him and where he's at where
he stands in the box
what a great swing you know i mean to
stay back latroy and use your hands like
that third career leadoff home run for
buxton and that brings us to donaldson
who's recorded 11 hits this season
donaldson
he's just he's on 100 all day long like
his energy level is so high in the
clubhouse and donaldson clocks that one
to deep left
forget about it
the twins go back to back to start the
game
josh donaldson records his second home
run of the season and it's two nothing
minnesota they're not messing around
here scotty they are coming out ready to
hit and uh
you know this is a really really good
offense the twins when they start
scoring runs
they're a dangerous team for sure i mean
that's right in his will house and you
know he stays back on the ball better
than you know some of the best in the
game
and
good results is gonna happen the twin
second baseman back in the lineup after
a day off yesterday he's won for his
last 12. talk about energy and what he
does up the middle and you know he's
just a dynamic type player that can get
the twin there you go heats he's off and
jorge polanco makes it three home runs
in the first for the twins
a burst of energy from this twins
offense it's 4-0
talk about pitchers having to pitch
ahead in the count and stay out of
hitters counts that 3-0 3-1 2-1 counts
when you put yourself in that situation
you give the hitters an opportunity to
do some damage like polanco on this 3-1
fastball jay happ on the mound and
latroy he's coming off one of the best
starts of his career he was five outs
away from no hitting pittsburgh in the
cold in his third start as a twin
he does and he picks up the strikeout
his first of the game
byron buxton trying to follow up his
homer to start the day and he swings at
the 3-2 and gets it past the infield
and that's going to move kirill off over
to third buxton with the hustle into
second he's got himself a double
there's so many things this guy does
from an offensive end from his base
running there's so many ways he wins
games latroy it's so impressive he he
might be if not the most dynamic player
right now
in the game as far as all the package
and that loads him up for nelson cruz
who has a grand slam this year that came
early in detroit nelson cruz loud
contact to right field and it's off the
top of the wall
that's gonna score a couple for
minnesota nelson cruz contributing the
two run single it's six nothing
minnesota
almost left the yard would have been his
11th career grand slam
nelson cruz pounded that baseball to
right
buxton scores along with kiriloff
that is really neat there's rosario
going the other way and it's gone
i met rosario on an o2 pitch
has teed off and the indians are on the
board rosario's second home run of the
season comes off half cleveland breaks
the ice
another beautiful swing fellas that ball
must be uh must be going out to right
field
and willian's astor dio is coming up
mastadio
pulls that one down the line and
it's gone
la tortuga goes long it's the fourth
home run of the day for the twins we're
only in the third astor dio's second of
the season make it 7-1 minnesota
beautiful swing scotty
breaking ball here and stayed right on
it and again you know what a nice level
beautiful swing
seventh fastest in terms of sprint speed
in the american league
just shy of 29 feet per second that is
blazing speed he can do it all
and he goes after the first pitch and he
finds open space on the right side j.p
morosi what else can you add to the
vibrant display of skills that byron
buxton brings to the table every day
well scott first of all it's the fourth
inning and buxton is now a triple shy of
the cycle
what a tortuga mitch garver blasts that
baseball and
it is gone wow wow
on cue
i can't wait to hear what nelson cruz
said on that one you can see him
celebrating again in the dugout
garber after two strikeouts this time
blasts off for his third of the
season it's a breaking ball breaking
down and in garber
who's able to get the barrel to that
ball and hit it off the facing
that's the only blemish rosario gets to
him he is coming off
a lot of no-hit baseball against
pittsburgh rosario going the other way
again this time in fairground and he
doesn't have it
brent rooker lined it up but it's off
the glove rosario's into second with a
lead-off double
rosario's the only guy that's trying to
hit the ball to the opposite field that
was a great
um
attempt by brent rooker riddle's a
little further away here's the 1-1 swung
on ground ball to short
simmons will throw to first and it's in
time for the out scoring from third is
rosario always really respected how that
organization uh brought all you guys up
and how you guys grew into great young
men
buxton is going to pull off an infield
single he is not going to lock the
triple just yet but
wow can he move
carver has definitely worked very hard
worked very hard at you know being a
better catcher framing his presentation
has gotten way better and him calling
the game has gotten better also and him
blasting home runs looks really good
today
mitch garver circa 2019 there he goes
again it's a two home run performance
doubling his total on the season to four
and the twins have a double digit run
day
garber very good against left hand
he's been outstanding the day against
him hopefully this starts a trend
straight across the board and those are
traits that you can't
you can't
you can't pay for
what about the traits that byron buxton
has this afternoon
a five-hit day handles the breaking
stuff it's his first career five-hit
performance all smiles
this afternoon congrats on the milestone
and many to come for young byron buxton
27 years old and his april has been
fantastic
first series of the season between the
indians and the twins and this should do
it
the twins topped the indians by a final
score of 10-2 off six home runs this
afternoon